[Music]
hey everyone its Alicia Malone welcome
to another episode of Fandango in Bee
Movie Guide and I actually only have one
film to tell you about this week but
it's a very very good one I tanea this
stars and it was produced by Margot
Robbie and it's all about the life of
Tonya Harding and yes that incident
between Tonya Harding and Nancy Kerrigan
what can you tell us about Tonya Harding
I don't know what Toni hearted aren't
you her bodyguard the thing that may
surprise some people about this movie I
know it took me by surprise in a good
way
was it stone this is a dark comedy and
it's written so well that it walks a
fine line between being very funny and
absurd at times and also making you feel
for Tonya Harding because she came from
a lower income family than Nancy
Kerrigan how that was played out in the
media the brass when it really to be the
pile of crap
I never did this it has a wonderful
performance by Allison Janney look out
for her to be nominated for Best
Supporting Actress and Margot Robbie is
wonderful once again she is an
Australian treasure you can see I tanya
out in cinemas from this weekend
[Music]
so because that's the only new film out
in theaters I can talk about this week I
want to run through a couple of films
that you should definitely try and catch
while you have time over the holidays
call me by your name I think that will
be my number one film of 2017 a
beautiful heartbreaking love story the
shape of water
onigumo del toro could make this kind of
magical monster movie and make you
believe that a woman will fall in love
with a fish man the disaster artist a
sweet and very inspiring story about a
man who just wants to make a movie sure
it's Tommy Wise oh and one of the worst
movies of all time the room but James
Franco and his brother Dave Franco
really sell their the best friend story
Lady Bird you guys know how much I love
this charming coming-of-age story about
a high school student in her last year
before she goes to college Saoirse Ronan
is fantastic and Greta Gerwig direction
and script adds such a fun fresh
unexpected edge three billboards outside
Epping Missouri another dark comedy that
walks that fine line in tone Frances
McDormand Sam Rockwell Woody Harrelson
fantastic ensemble cast great script and
direction by Martin McDonagh
if you loved Seven Psychopaths and in
bruges then definitely check out three
billboards outside a Bing
Missouri has a lot to say about America
right now - lots of suggestions there
for you as we head into award season I'm
sure many of those films will be talked
about in conversations Golden Globe
nominations are out next week
I'm Alicia Malone so let me know on
Twitter a deletion alone or in the
comments below
which film do you hope gets Awards
attention this year I love to hear from
you and I'll see you next week
you